I was into some precarious situations  meaning that I didn't know any better I  was I was not equipped for I was not  okay so if you're if you're from a  family of lawyers you kind of yeah we're  gonna you're gonna be a lawyer or you  know military families a lot of guys  follow or women following the footsteps  of their father and join you know and go  down range and join so you're kind of  raised by the thing around you so when  there's no one there when the goal is  survival you figure it out and for me  when it came to you know hustling and  dealing drugs and doing whatever I was  doing it was just because it was the  only thing I knew how to do I always say  that no criminal wants to do crime they  just do it because they don't really  [ __ ] know what else to do